citizens of the reject Nation it is time for
what what is it for what what if what if season
2 episode 8 the most under promoted Good Thing
Marvel has done ever and I am surprised because
it is it is a great season have you guys been
feeling what do you think about episode 8 we
do not get access to know what the title is in
advance which is exciting we only have two left
so I think this is 1602 you know I'm going to
do right now I'm going to I'm going to oh but
but in case you do like a big o face for thumb
know that happens to work yeah we got to block
them there we go now they won't hear me but I'll
have a good expression that's what it counts man
that's a reaction leave a like people that would
be great also subscribe click the notification
Bell to get notify when our reaction for
the finale is up here on the channel big
thank you to preer for helping us Ed down this
hot lot and full L Reaction watch along for to
sync up with your own copy of what if that's
available for super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page patreon page M thank you to all
who have joined us so far and John and I cover
several things exclusively with highlights
and watch alongs included let's watch the
pen ultimate ultimate ultimate ultimate episod
episod what if if we've been filming too many
hours tune in
1602 1602 got to be little flute little
little pipe and flute to be or not to
be Billy shakes that is the question
what tomon to suffer the slings and
arrows of Outrageous Fortune is he doing
a play or to take arms against a sea of
troubles and B my opposing end them he's
actually an a theater actor I love that
Shakespeare is happening to die that
is not acting is hello on the throne
yes no not again everybody's wanted
Hemsworth and Heston in the same scene
again Happ true it's no a rift in time
and space 1602 Bal gam have you read it
uhuh it's incredible that's this Captain
you're up no TR returns this was in the
rehears he's still giving a monolog oh
my God so nice of me to drop in lucky
you my
queen oh this is going to be awesome it's
beautiful
oh hang
on no sister when him and Hela got along in one
Universe a Time Stone The Queen Is Gone
technically King Thor Odin son congratulations
Long Live King Thor Nick Fury bowing to as well oh
my God they all surf your highness I am I'm truly
sorry sorry o my king I am I she is cursed sees
her oh damn do you mind if I borrow that that's my
yor PO yorck I want her alive Shakespeare jokes
summon the witch I'd have words about her hero
oh was sweet we saw how that episode ended but I'm
curious how this all started cuz remember she got
pulled in Yeah Yeah by the witch King marred by
loss a soldier on the Run the World on the brink
of Oblivion cool but how does a Time displaced
super soldier end up with such a strangely
familiar reality the sad truth is that there are
worlds among the Multiverse so cool simply meant
to die this feels the season feels bigger too
like this is like this has a magnitude to it oh
1,000% a band of Heroes gathered together to save
their reality the Scarlet wh Wanda maximoff used
her powers to reach into a neighboring Universe
for a warrior like Captain Peggy Carter yeah got
it the captain joined the heroes of 16002 in
their desperate bid to save their world what
a crazy timeline this Peggy Carter has put yes
with no way home no place to go the very rack of
Thor I can hear you you know wait really you can
you're fighting a battle you can't can't possibly
understand two time periods the 1600s and the
early 21st century have been compressed stuck
together like two pieces of gum good detail
impressive if I don't find a way to unstick
these time periods this universe will shatter
The overarching Narrative what's that for I'm
going to take you back to your Universe I'm
not leaving worlds die every day I've watched
Millions fade from existence it happens well not
on my watch going to save million universes Peg
by herself but I still believe she is the key to
our survival for I sense there is another person
from a time that is still to come poppy [__]
calm yourself Hogan mind your Affliction a future
person more of a lost traveler a forerunner
who has fallen through time unaware that their
presence is causing our universe to collapse I
like seeing Thor as this ruler yeah the arrogance
is back and the ignorance and how great H shall
we find this fellow the answer is beyond even my
capabilities sounds like you have your mission I
like how the Scarlet Witch is actually a witch for
the king wit I'm so happy for Elizabeth Olsson
that's start oh what what friend of yours more
like a souvenir huh you're right the stuff gives
off an energy probably radioactive o wait active
what now God I love your madeup words I need more
of this flux capacitor yes I need more of this
I just think the C the back and forth between
everyone is so much better this time they must
have recorded in the same room can you trace it in
theory yes Magic needed to power such a device no
AR reactors in 1602 again with the beautiful
gibberish keep talking it's like opium to my
ears it's like opium there is one thing rumored
to have enough power to propel a thousand ships
out on New King will let me borrow his scepter
sounds like you need a thief to help you steal
it oo who's the thief Hulk Hawkeye Hawkeye
makes more sense Hulk Iago I mean there's
some other characters in it but really the plays
about Iago poor U is such a good joke they yeah
Hawkeye it's like a Robin Hood he's he's like
a Robin Hood and a period appropriate outfit
wait no is that Captain America your Carriage
looks like it could use some lightning of its
load Rogers hood No Way Outlaw you're annoyingly
chipper they knew what they were doing yeah they
did that both they knew they pineapple cakes
marip that's L it's actually red we're here
for the coin not the cake Lang now maybe you are
oh there's pie too chag it's very expensive it's
the most expensive episode of Television yeah
this must be some trickery or a ghost from my
made Margaret pass to the other side many moons
ago I'm dead in this world that's great sorry I
mean that's terrible pgy she gets to see a buff
version of Steve everybody wins everybody wins
hi hi I could do this all day have you guys
tried these de claes they're amazing they
blow your mind in every Universe Paul red has a
food thing I love how we're in England but some
of them are just American just English yeah in
your world is there another Steve Rogers oh yeah
he's a little skinny guy skinny guy tell me what
he's like little skinny guy no no beard no beard
for sure I don't think I will will you help
me I know I'm not your Peggy but my Margaret
would want to save this world too that was her
specialty oh my God Peggy do it with him he's
probably a syphilis statistically what is that
oh no man we've got company what is happening
what oh it's little yellow jackets oh cool Royal
Yellow Jackets yes Royal Yellow Jackets the king
wants C alive the rest is up to you I love
this so much oh my God I love this so much
instead of the arrow can't stand Cofe C don't
worry L you Corner the market on being a pest
they actually have a really good chemistry of
the three of them yeah true that's true great
this season so good at teams like assembling
teams and Dynamics you were ingesting about the
king hating you he thinks I killed his sister
yeah that would do it look at him he's the oh
smart yes yes love tracking shots at
the action them sharing the shield
just fills me with such happiness
that is so cool that's AES so
good get it there's some great Shield
choreography this season and then music
that Bucky don't make him mad Would we not like
him when he's mad is he a
is he a B I think we just
won oh the annihilator yeah
Destroyer Destroyer I made it
bigger damn look at this looks like a Disney
animated movie but a good one like a handdrawn
one when they made them with care and money go
find Star I'll be right behind you I'll draw
their fire and cover your exit men you
heard the lady Retreat this world feels
so lived in and thought out want a whole
602 you got to read the books think this
true fool hey watch the blood pressure Hogan
oh it's happy Hogan I thought so earlier the
voice but then he got like Angry in another
world we all friends me you star HT in another
world I'm a compatriot with that madman star
well this is different I I do need Peggy to
sweat a little bit well yeah we talked about
that in our one yeah yeah just need a tiny
just tiny bit of struggle is that red School
looked like it very brief though couldn't tell
but this is the ultimate like amalgamation of
of what a what if scenario is even if you find
and destroy this Forerunner what happens
next what if the world doesn't magically
correct itself what if it's the final straw
that destroys this universe what if what if
what if what if what if you die what if what if
what if sounds like this I have to try the whole
what if is all based in worries what if this
some sort of Suicide Squad and if you're not
going to help me get out of my way that might
be my favorite Captain Carter outfit this is so
cool great tracking shot holy crap
it's Soldier tastic this is so and
super tight yeah Rogers told me about you
the monster in the iron Mas we could use
your help sh go away yeah but we need you
I don't do that anymore I can't handle the
aggravation it's quiet in the cell put
him as the Man in the Iron Mas so much
peace and quiet stop that solitary oh yes
more Barbarian Hulk give me that Savage
this might be the visually prettiest episode
to me like the lighting here these costumes
Hulk Hulk with the beard
Maestro run
under riding him yes wow Hulk By Night Loy
people wrong I know buddy Peggy will fix it I
hope painting gorgeous painting here Banner this
will set you straight and nude I like how there
are Rifts on like The Avengers movie like the
first one like a receptor and everything which
led me to finishing my greatest invention ever
ignore that it's decorative your stunned silence
is flattering though I'm not opposed to Applause
this love is like not a respected mad sizes oh
like love me it will reveal the Forerunner and
send them back from whence they came once you
know the prized Royal stone is inserted storm
of the castle got of our thing Steve well lady
sorry we're late got her Shield back wrestle this
from some Palace guards on the way over I thought
you might need it touching would have gone with a
Sonet personally you guys are so cute during the
upcoming court session we'll enter in Disguise
Lords and Ladies from across the kingdom will be
there so will the Forerunner Tony will line wait
with a device we get the stone and save the world
they're doing like several Avengers movies he's
a CL man and he's a military man and he um it's
an annoying actor I love Tom hson just having
joy as ass in my ear one more time why do you
hate music so much why do you hate music
so much it's a great Easter egg St is upon
us now or never what's the signal it's interesting
to see Thor portrayed most like Odin yeah signal
signal come on Buck together
we'll teach them to dance
Ma damn the way they have re visioned Bucky
is perfect man I love to swash buckle Loki
let us join the fry brother where's
the hammer I got you I have misplaced
it my king we are short on time coming
through make a hole hey I'm walking
here per God I want this Hulk back taste
my steel you vile truy onioning my your
face revokes me I like he was actually good with a
sword sir Hogan I am so sorry great job
Rogers you made him mad good luck is he
like an Abomination oh there's the purple
version too he's got it here too somehow
he's a Hulk that's cool to tie it in yeah I
don't know how but it's great fetch me the old
father it's vibranium coronation gift from
the king of wakanda Steve we have trouble
got a little trouble of my own Rifts
in space relating to the live action
oh it' be great wouldn't it this is quite a
[__] you got there th please we can stop
this oh Father give me strength you're
more of a drama queen than your brother
bless easy I I I could get you a new feather
oh there we go yeah hul smash
thee Hulk smash thee oh my God
this cool yeah okay and is given
just as much respect as he was
in woo woo great fight fights
both fights are all the fights
happen are great next time no Hulk who
I Surrender now only Tony can get in the
fight I've got enough of your devilry interesting
to have a weapon that combines with his thunderous
abilities weapon yeah what I'm sorry so medieval
epic we're out of time Fury what are you doing
find me an opening treason get the to St here
we go what a finale yeah we still have one
more you got to be kidding me St it's
only a failure if it explodes come on
pegy now what does she have to do
oh is it going to be the Iron Man
suit from Iron Man suit to like cover
her oh she got gauntlets oh yeah whoa
what did it's him him the Forerunner he's
the future man that's impossible I remember
a battle we were fighting a monster from the
skies armed with a Golden Glove no went to
strike with hit one of the stones instead oh
it's still alternate version okay it's true
Carter was right I thought it was going to
be him going back giving the stones through
time and I was like are we about to get a Canon
event like Carter don't be a fool finish your
task the one you were summoned for py oh is me
any experienced Amnesia we both know what I need
to do and have seia my lady oh they always have
to say goodbye o every Universe except for one
after a while we never get our happy ending you
do once I'm sure somewhere out there we do a oh
he does it oh dud this season is so good I like
really felt that [__] dad that was incredible
damn that victory was its own sort of curse
because every battle you won would mean you're
only getting further from home yeah yeah it's not
really a Superstition come here to gloat tell me
that I'm stuck here forever is it strange no I
just thought you could use a friend yeah what
are you doing here oh have I got a story to
tell you I love how he's just been continuing
on yeah part one for the finale favorite episode
that's favorite new favorite how was everything I
wanted what is this season I like want to like I
wish there was like a Mr Marvel I be like Marvel
this is what you should be promoting I know my
God God guys why haven't you bought a shirt yet
I don't get it Coy similarly vexing at reation
shop.com you can get shirts like this one you see
on screen and this one too and then this one as
well and also this one which I enjoy and there's
another one and there's so much more it's like the
best way to support the channel we love they were
part of how they exist and it's also you know
we're creatively involved we got more to Comon
did you get money for the holidays spend it there
anyway cool let's talk about this but episode like
that was crazy like that was so many like what
what do what do what do you want this is going
to sound strange this has weirdly been the show
that has massively regained my faith in Marvel
I was thinking not just that because I agree
but I was also thinking this is not this just
the show that's getting me back into the like
Avengers scope team up organizized organizized
organized but also it made me realize how much
I miss certain things I miss Savage Hulk I miss
the dynamic feeling like it's already established
not like they're trying to build out I miss things
feeling less chaotic Ironically in a chaotic show
called what if like it's doing all of the things
that I forgot like when you rewatch something you
can never experience it for the first time again
this feels like I'm experiencing old Marvel for
the first time again yes let me elaborate because
like do I think the show is better than Loki
season 2 no I don't no I don't think it's but does
it feel more like a traditional Marvel thing in a
great way I think what they have done is the thing
is with Loki season 2 they're telling one story
right Guardians 3 they're telling one story and
in our story Coy loves to play with his mic when
Greg's talking it's great it's his favorite it's a
great habit he's in my head it's a visual thing
but it's obviously an auditory thing but it's
but my brain doesn't compute that there is that
what you think yes it's not a flute C it is H his
microphone that's your thumb where's your stray
jacket ah anyway they are doing a variety of
different stories and on top of that too it is a
SE a sophomore season to a season that left a lot
of people feeling like it's fine I know people
skipping this season because of how season one
made them feel if this was season 1 then I would
put what if in my top third of Marvel my point
is they knew how to improve they knew how to
take something improve it they have brought us
a variety of different stories they have showed
us like no we really do know these characters and
love them and that's why because this is embracing
the whole MCU this season and like lowkey season
2 was phenomenal and my favorite of the Marvel
stuff so far this year however this is this is a
completely different type of thing from Loki but
also kind of similar because Multiverse whatever
but do you get my point of why why I would say
like like Loki I'm like yeah Loki's kind of like
this isolated story I love Loki versus love the I
love that that story they're telling this is MCU
you know right Loki's got more in common with like
your sci-fi Doctor Who stuff whereas this feels
like the MCU yeah which I which I had missed yeah
and that's why and and an episode like this which
is an Avengers tale like one of my favorite is a
very different comic I haven't read 1602 comic um
but one of my favorite Comics I read when I was
a kid was Batman thrill killer have you read that
um where it's like Batman in the ' 50s or 40s
something like that where and it's some type of
idea where you take these characters and you put
them it's like a Gotham by gam slam kind of thing
yeah and um and so I always love those ideas and I
and I really think they brought that to life here
in a very very strong way I think it's excellent
like the the way they swapped out every character
here with where you even even though Steve is
connected to modern day there were like Clues
like hey his appearance his buff and he's got
the shield yeah the shield was like the biggest
giveaway they kept using it I kept being like I
should feel suspicious and I wasn't I was just
like but where they put um you know Bucky the kind
of role he served Hogan the deliciousness of Paul
rud's comedy yeah Paul rut's comedy um and but
even when happy Hogan to be like that sniveling
servant yes and another Hulk Hogan but like of
course because of that many variations there might
be another universe that has him get those Powers
I loved that Banner as the as the man of the Iron
Mask lro Banner brilliant play Oh everyone oh
freaking Tony Stark as like the mad scientist
who's like not really respected I should not have
laughed that hard at Hulk smash the like that was
so much joy smash that was like pure and did know
Mark Ruffo got to say that in a booth like just
me picturing how happy Mark Ruffo must be to like
get to do this Hulk again Scarlet Witch man and
like Elizabeth Olsen getting to be a witch getting
to be the actual witch who serves and this writer
you know probably watched ju division so I really
enjoyed her getting to be the character that she
wants to play I really think that what they did
here was excellent and every so many episodes this
season and and especially this one have left me
feeling like I wish we could watch a whole series
out of these characters out of this like they
announced they wanted to do Marvel zombies um
I would much rather see Marvel 1602 I would much
rather see Marvel also they they confirmed season
three of this at the at the event they whatever
that small event yeah I hope it's as good as this
cuz this is exceptional this is making me want
a lot more Marvel whereas lately Marvel's I've
been like you know slowing Down's not the worst
yeah like you know what I mean next year we get
we get Deadpool as the only live action but next
year we also get three animated series and like if
they're as good as this holy crap and the mirror
reflectiveness that they were doing between Peggy
and Steve throughout when they both get to be
the prime like you know enhanced super soldier
serum versions of themselves where Peggy went down
the same path as uh as Captain America and you're
watching them interact with each other and the
choreography that was when her Soldier mirroring
and then all the Avengers stuff and Shakes Loki oh
my God the poror line was such a deep cut well not
that deep but it's like a medium cut Shakespeare
like film student joke that was such a good joke
I this is my favorite episode like this is what I
love about the Avengers this is what I love about
wha ifs this is what I love about the cast because
they got to play at like this level together
this is what I love about the power of Animation
because 1602 might have looked silly with actors
in it this is all of the reasons to make a wh if
in one episode and uh this is also a comic that I
love dearly the 1602 Neil game and run is is I I
I hold it near and dear to my heart so this being
adapted this beautifully was so fun this was great
they all have like personalities my least favorite
episode this season is still better than most of
last season oh absolutely two yeah yeah still I
think a lot of people really like that one um I
don't know it's still on for me that's the only
one I'm like kind of on the bottom of it's not
not bad it's just I think it's the only one that
didn't stick The Landing all of but the problems
that I have with that one could have hap could
have occurred here with oh look at these different
Avengers roster characters all showing up in this
big Ensemble episode but every everyone here
even if they they even if they don't have a lot
of screen time they had like at least something
that allowed them to really shine in one moment
right you know and I think the mix and matching
of everyone was excellent and so I I unlike that
episode where I was like oh cool we got this guy
this guy this guy didn't do much yeah they didn't
feel utilized this they felt utilized everyone
was properly utilized and uh guys I got a little
bit of brainwave power left in me my voice I have
been fighting everything in me to not sound like
I'm coming down for the sore because certainly am
a lot of talking yesterday I can't do I can't do
what you do qu it's not easy and I don't know
how but I lose it and I get really sick this
is the first year since you've known me that I
haven't gotten sick in DEC I've been taking so
much vitamin C it is the only thing combating
this right now last year I almost went deaf
permanently and the year before that I got covid
the year before that I had a flu I as long as I've
known you this time of year I'm usually clinging
to life so uh we've both been working on taking
care of ourselves obnoxious amount of antioxidants
we've got one more episode left one more episode
we and then I'm going to go work on video then
you're going to edit silence don't worry don't
worry people that think Greg doesn't do enough
he's still working don't worry I got it guys
he's just doing it in silence this is this is the
you guys going to see the fun part yeah don't you
worry while you're resting at home we're filming
and editing yeah you guys get the fun side rela
and then I'll do the other stuff tomorrow fin what
is happened it's like a demon outside I was like
a loud squeaky demon we'll see you tomorrow
see you tomorrow finale much love happy New
Year